qu'avait bonjour merci être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france à leur
première question 36 ans après que
reste-t-il de la sphère du rainbow
warrior et bien en fait ce sont un peu
les prémices d'une histoire qui continue
malheureusement aujourd'hui puisqu'on
voit que les relations entre l'état
français malheureusement et les
organisations écologistes ne sont
toujours pas pacifié
depuis il ya eu de nombreuses autres
actions menées contre des militants
écologistes
on se souvient de ces images en pas si
longtemps que ça sur le pont sully en
juin 2019 ou les militants écologistes
étaient gazés par les forces de l'ordre
2018 les 2500 militaires qui sont amenés
à déloger les 150 personnes sur la zad
de notre dame des landes
mais je pense aussi à la mort de rémy
fraysse qui a toujours pas été élucidée
le coupable n'a toujours pas été
condamné c'est un militant écologiste
qui se battaient pour sauvegarder la
zone de civens et puis des images en
fait qui nous parviennent encore par
exemple dans ce film je pense au film
plogoff des pierres contre des fusils et
les images justement d'aider des soldats
et des gendarmes français envoyés contre
les manifestants qui refusent
l'installation des centrales nucléaires
sur les territoires français et
notamment en bretagne et donc on a cette
histoire de luttes écologistes parfois
violentes qui démontre qu'il ya en fait
une absence de discussions entre les
différents gouvernements qui se sont
succédé et les militants écologistes qui
urge en fait ce rapport à la nature qui
doit évoluer pour faire entendre
l'urgence climatique l'urgence en
matière de biodiversité et on voit que
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui luttes écologistes plus que
jamais d'actualité
on connaît l'organisation greenpeace
pour cette mission coup de poing à
travers le monde mais aussi en france
est ce que les populations ils sont
sensibles à ces opérations coup de poing
oui je pense effectivement c'est un
moyen de lutte qui nous montre aussi que
très concrètement des choses sont
possibles
on peut agir sur le terrain par exemple
contre les projets miniers en guyane
française nous nous sommes mobilisés
nous avons mené des actions nous avons
monté des marches des protestations
contre la mine et nous avons réussi à
faire plier emmanuel macron qui a fini
par retirer ou au moins à suspendre le
projet minier montagne d'or germé dans
certaines situations évidemment tout ça
est très compliqué et aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il est plus qu urgent que le
gouvernement cesse de voir les
organisations écologistes comme des
ennemis mais commence à s'ouvrir aux
discussions parce que on l'a vu par
exemple dans le cas de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat que le
gouvernement a délibérément coulé par le
fond justement comme le rainbow warrior
il ya vraiment un problème d'écouté et
de collaboration avec ceux qui
s'engagent pour la protection de
l'intérêt général et des droits des
générations futures est la dernière
question parle beaucoup de la
responsabilité de l'état comment
jugez-vous les actions du gouvernement
en terme en matière d'écologie
aujourd'hui excusez moi de dire que je
suis extrêmement choqué en fait par
cette relation qu'il ya entre le
gouvernement justement et les militants
écologistes puisqu'en fait il ya plus de
subtilité qu'à l'époque six mois ces
actions directes ont fait sauter un
bateau mais la perversité de ce
gouvernement qui annonce des actes
politiques en faveur du climat
et quand on regarde dans les détails en
fait il ne s'agit que de mesures est d'
annonce qui ne sont pas à la hauteur et
d'ailleurs se sont pas les militants
écologistes qui le disent c'est le
conseil d'état c'est le haut conseil
pour le climat se sont toutes les
instances de la république tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
aujourd'hui et donc il ya vraiment un
problème nous par exemple qui nous
sommes battus pour la reconnaissance du
crime déco steed et cette proposition a
été confisquée par le gouvernement a été
détournée reformuler vidé de sa
substance
et donc aujourd'hui je m'inquiète très
fortement justement de ce gouvernement
qui privilégie les opérations de
communication aux actions en profondeur
et on se demande justement où ça va nous
mener
alors il calme et merci beaucoup d'avoir
réagi ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que cette présidente de
l'association wild légal qui a pour
objectif de former aux droits de la
nature